This brings us to the end of the lessons
about Google Analytics and Tag Manager.
Hopefully now you know how to add the
code to your app to send tracking data,
whether you send it directly to Google
Analytics, or send it via Tag Manager.
I've barely scratched the surface in
terms of the data insights you can get
from Google Analytics.
There's so
much more to say about how to slice and
dice the data, get custom segments,
send reports, and get custom views.
Our friends over at Google Analytics
Academy have more courses you can take
focused on to use your Analytics
data to understand and
improve the way your app is used.
And that's what tracking your
app's usage data is all about.